what's the worst steak you've ever had  so i was in russia and i had a difficult  time sourcing good quality meat they  full on use some spray on their meat  that i react to so it was really hard to  find meat that hadn't been sprayed  because they sprayed at the butchers or  the slaughterhouse so we had to go to a  farm and get meat that i didn't react to  it was a huge pain we bought this cow we  had this cow we ordered meat from the  cow we didn't directly go to pick it up  so someone else brought meat i had one  of these steaks woke up at four in the  morning with really horrible food  poisoning called them the next day and  they're like oh yeah sorry that was for  a restaurant a restaurant sorry we meant  to send that to the restaurant first of  all what restaurants i can never go  there because i just was violently ill  so yeah it was meant for a restaurant  which it definitely wasn't they  definitely just stole the cow and gave  us crappy steak that was the worst steak  i've had